This Sunday, the South Terminal
at London's Gatwick Airport
will reopen to the public after
nearly two years closed.
And I figured that reopening would
just be a case of the team here
turning the lights back on,
dusting off some equipment,
and getting back to business.
But from talking to the folks
who are getting everything ready,
it turns out that mothballing an entire
airport terminal for 18 months
and then reopening it again
is much more difficult
than you might think.
- In March 2020 when the pandemic struck,
we obviously realized
there was going to be a
significant downturn in traffic.
So we took the decision to close
one of our terminals.
Gatwick Airport would generally see
upwards of 900 movements off of
our runway on a busy summer day.
During the height of the pandemic, we
were down to two or three flights a day
with certainly less than
500 passengers on certain days.
I think it's fair to say,
in March 2020 we all thought
it'd be over in two weeks' time.
- If the terminal had been shut down
for just a week, or maybe a month,
then yes, things would probably
have just kept ticking over.
But there's some point at
which upkeep is required.
In the same way that you're not meant
to leave a car sitting unused
for more than a couple of weeks,
the mechanical parts in things like
the baggage belts and jetbridges
need to be run, tested,
and maintained regularly,
or they might not start up ever again.
Closing the terminal does
reduce costs, yes,
but it doesn't make them zero.
- There's a number of core services
we've had to keep running.
We had to do regular maintenance
and safety checks on all of our
passenger boarding bridges
and airfield equipment.
Water systems, lighting systems,
power, fire, life safety systems,
everything that's there to look after
the people and keep everyone safe.
But things like, you know,
heating and lighting in various areas
nd power for escalators and lifts,
they were all shut down.
Mainly to save money during the crisis,
we had to make cuts wherever possible.
We've been taking the opportunity
to use the space for filming.
Film companies have been coming in and
doing various shows around the airport.
Some of which, I think, will be airing
in the next few weeks.
A large number of our workforce
had been furloughed,
and since the 1st of October,
we've had everyone back in
to get the airport back up and running.
Now as passenger numbers start to grow,
we are actively recruiting
and we need to increase our workforce
by a significant number.
We're reopening 85% of it straight away.
We've got a phased plan for our airlines
moving back over from North Terminal
over three days,
but all the infrastructure will come
online more or less from day one.
In terms of a challenge?
Yeah, it's the biggest one
I've done at Gatwick airport.
It's been open for 60-odd years,
that's now been closed for the
best part of two years.
You know, buildings don't react
too well to that sort of thing.
The scale of what
we're doing here is...
we've often likened it to
opening a smaller airport,
completely from scratch.
It is a huge task that we're undertaking.
I'm feeling really confident, actually.
I think we're in a really good place to do
it.
- The first flight from the South Terminal
is scheduled to leave on Sunday
in the early hours of the morning.
So it'll probably be about 3am when the
first passengers go through the doors.
And they probably won't know or care
that the terminal's only just
opened again:
they'll just want to get
to their destination.
If everything goes to plan,
they probably won't even know
that the terminal was ever closed.